we're incredibly excited to have you
here we have a lot of material that we
want to cover today if you will spend
about the first third talking about
Walmart's business globally the second
third talking a little bit about your
personal leadership experience and then
we'll save the last third for questions
from our audience for get started though
I'd actually like to hit on some news
from last week and a blog post on the
Walmart website you announced the
starting associate store sources yet pay
in the US was going up to $9 an hour and
this year and next year to $10 an hour
along with a variety of other changes to
the way you manage your store associates
I'm curious why this change and why now
why not we've been joking the leadership
at Walmart about how cool it is to go to
work on a day and give 500,000 people a
raise I hope you get to do that someday
it's really really pretty great we we
were just trying to run great stores and
for those of you that don't have
experience in retail I think you'd be
surprised at how many decisions we make
how many variables there are so we just
think about a store for example you've
got to have engaged associates I've got
to care about what they're doing so you
need to think about the wage rate you
need to think about the opportunity that
they have you need to think about
healthcare you need to think how many
hours about how many hours you're
scheduling and I could go on and on and
on but the changes we announced last
week here in the US for walmart and
Sam's Club or largely aimed at creating
a better store experience and and I'm
sure we'll talk some about the internet
and about how technology is changing the
business but our strategy is to find
ways to bring stores and Technology
together in a way that exceed customer
expectations and excite them so to do
that you've got to have great people
that are excited about their opportunity
at Walmart and that's that's what this
is is designed to do great and in your
explanation of the changes in a call for
shareholders you explained it in largely
economic terms so they're largely the
terms you used here that better store
associate pay leads to a better store
experience and eventually more profit
for Walmart now there's another line of
argument about associate pay that
focuses on a very different logical
tract focuses on
this is it the Walmart has a moral
responsibility to give a living wage or
that there's you know other
considerations beyond the you know store
experience and the profit to Walmart I'm
curious to what extent did those
considerations also enter the decision
was it largely driven by economic
reasoning it's both but it's mainly
about running a good business our
philosophy is if we run a great business
society will benefit communities will
benefit now we are using the size and
scale the company to engage in
sustainability social and environmental
sustainability in fact we were here
today having a milestone meeting with
our folks in our e-commerce business it
was broadcast around the this hemisphere
I suppose talking about what we're doing
is it relates to the environment as it
relates to the obligation we have turn
on people the way we think about it is
that we're trying to design a
meritocracy
so you heard that I started out
unloading trucks eventually got into the
buyer training program worked as an
assistant manager in a store and then
was lucky enough to move into her home
office and start managing categories
which was a lot of fun more fun that I
would have dreamt and I just fell into
it I wasn't planning on being in retail
didn't have designed to be at Walmart it
just kind of happened but but what
happened for me and what has happened
for many other people we employed 2.2
million people around the world is that
you get in and you have an opportunity
to exceed your own expectations about
what's possible so our design is one
where we try to create the first rung of
the ladder to be one that people can
reach so you could say Walmart should
pay a living wage to every associate and
then that first rung would go up but
there would be many people who couldn't
reach it and they might not have jobs
and they might not have an opportunity
so if you want to start as a cashier in
Walmart and learn how to work in retail
learn what it means to give good
customer service learn what it means to
keep a store in stock etc then you can
move on to becoming a customer service
manager you might become a department
manager which next year will pay $15 an
hour you might become an assistant
manager start making $50,000 an hour
you might become a store manager and
make
fifteen hundred eighty thousand dollars
an hour and just work your way your way
on up in the business to do whatever it
is it was that you tripped up or you're
capable of doing let's say so we want a
meritocracy we want a ladder of
opportunity and I'm proud of that I
don't have any issue with explaining
that to people and do all the time and
really I think it's the American Dream
and there are people and I met one the
other day we had our what we call our
your beginning meeting with store
managers we pulled them all together in
Orlando and we were talking about this
phrase that's existed in the company way
back to 1979 our people make the
difference that was one of the subjects
that we were covering at that meeting
and when it was over with this store
manager walked up to me and she said
Doug I just have to tell you thank you
for the opportunity that Walmart's
giving me I lived in North Carolina but
a few years ago I was divorced my
husband took all the money literally
became homeless for a while but so and
so she called up the store manager's
name gave me a chance to work in the in
the store as an hourly associate and now
I think it was four or five years later
she's running a super center and making
a great living and you know a tear in
her eye and there starts to become a
tear of mine that's that's what Walmer
is about and I'm proud of that it's
clearly been a little great potful for
you to develop your career and I'd like
to delve into that a little bit later
but right now actually I'd like to focus
on the scope of the business globally so
before you were CEO you ran Walmart's
international business and under your
leadership it grew to be more than 6,000
stores and 26 countries outside the
United States some major acquisitions
there's the math smart acquisition that
brought you into many parts of southern
Africa but also some bumps along the way
there's the revaluation of the JV in
India and pulling out of Korea and
Germany so I'm curious given you know
lots of experience in many different
countries what did you learn about
scaling a business globally as later
Wallman international it can be
complicated we learn from experience and
I think our organization has learned
from experience if I if I started with
Germany which goes way back and
we tried to install our culture too fast
into that organization we tried to teach
them the Walmart cheer and hand them to
our technology and say let's go like all
at once and it just blew up we had two
companies that we bought we tried to put
them together and the the way we were
thinking about the business was not
sophisticated and we didn't listen
enough and it was just purely out of
ignorance we had the best of intentions
but it didn't work so he fast forward to
the last few years
government rules play a role if you look
at the situation in India where
currently multi-brand retail isn't
allowed from a foreign direct investment
point of view you have to have a JV you
have to have a relationship and that
relationship can be complicated and the
government can shift policies sometimes
in subtle ways that that change the
ground rules in our case today we've got
about twenty cash-and-carry units in
India they serve the kuranes the small
business owners in India we would like
to have a much bigger business but right
now about all we can do is just scroll
those cash-and-carry units and then and
then we'll see if the rules change in
Africa we used a principle that we've
developed over the last few years which
relates to scale some of the downsides
of an acquisition can be a cultural
alignment issue you can buy a business
that doesn't believe what you believe
and that will create all kinds of
problems in the case of mass Mart we
found one that was very culturally
aligned to who we were and that scale
buying a business that's big enough that
you can start to do business the way you
want to do business so for example we
like to practice every day low price
which has a lot attached to it including
how you negotiate with suppliers we
would like to not be paid to run
advertisements we would like to have a
lower cost every day and pass that on to
customers every day which creates supply
chain efficiency and helps our
productivity with work well you can't do
that if you have two stores
none suppliers will listen to you so
there are times when we need to grow
through acquisition to achieve some
level of scale there are other times
where the government situation or other
requirements prevent us from doing so
interesting so you mentioned there's one
more second a variety of different
strategies to enter
you mentioned acquisition some are green
field somewhere JD's so it sounds like
you're taking a portfolio approach in
the past in your strategies to continue
doing more the same that there isn't
necessarily one dominant way to enter a
new market that you've learned works
best yeah
like the way I would think about it is
on the front end closest to the customer
things need to be unique while it's true
that products are becoming more common
globally and I'm seeing pampers
everywhere you can't go to a country
without finding Colgate I mean these
brands are global in nature but the
decisions about what you carry and
subtleties around fresh food or a spice
or things like that require us to have a
local relevance and that means we've got
local buying teams so in the country we
have local talent making decisions about
how we go to market where we set prices
what items we carry running the stores
and all that kind of stuff
but on the back end there are things
we've learned about retail things
related to technology or the supply
chain by the business model itself that
need to be applied over time so what we
do is we hire great talent to run the
markets and then we give them tools and
resources that over time results in more
of a common culture and more of a common
business model and just one last thing
about that the internet is changing
things dramatically and the commonality
of what people read how they consume
media what they think what they hear
about that's pulling people together and
also causing retail to become more alike
in some ways the way that that mobile
and stores come together is going to be
more common around the country than it
is different it's interesting and then
you mentioned culture it's part of one
of the things you try to keep relatively
common across your different countries
and it's been something that you've
spoken quite a bit about as a leader in
Walmart we curious what specifically do
you do to try to ensure consistent
global culture because it sounds like
that'd be difficult given the eight
hundred thousand employees abroad in you
know 26 different countries yeah some of
you have a lot of work experience some
of you may not I don't think you can o
precise the importance of culture and
what we mean by that is behavior you can
have the most beautiful image of your
values on your
side or on your mobile app and that
means nothing if people don't actually
believe those things in act that way and
our culture comes from our founder if
you trace it all the way back the
characteristics of our founder Sam
Walton were strong and positive and then
even today even though he passed away in
1992 you can find characteristics of Sam
Walton and our business in Guatemala
characteristics of him in China
things like a customer service attitude
sense of urgency listening to your
associates those things have caused
success and they will cause success in
the future
and the way we articulate the things
that we talk about at Walmart as we
typically start with our purpose I'm not
sure I can remember exactly what year it
was but one of the presidents named Bush
came to Bentonville and gave an award to
to Sam before he passed away a
Presidential Medal of Freedom and he was
sick with cancer at the time and he
passed away fairly shortly after that
but he stood up out of his wheelchair
and said a number of things but one of
them was if we work together we can help
people around the world see what it's
like to save money and have a better
life and that phrase became save money
live better and that's our purpose so
around the world we're proud of that
core deliverable from the company our
purpose is important it's real it's
meaningful if you click down to values
we have four core values we have service
to the customer striving for excellence
respect for the individual relates to
things like listening and acting with
integrity and I think those are
universal truths that stand the test of
time and what we're trying to do at
Walmart is to get our everyday behaviors
of new associates we hired in a country
or those that have been around for a
while to just match up with those values
and when I go into a Walmart store and
it's not in good shape customers aren't
being treated well it's not in stock
maybe the stores not as clean as it
needs to be it you know breaks my heart
and I'm always trying to figure out okay
what could we have done better to create
a situation where that store manager and
those associates could have done a
better job so that Walmart lives up to
its potential doing that across 27
countries now that we're 52 years old is
harder
I think and what it might have been a
decade ago and what about the challenge
of maintaining those core values or
maintaining the same focus on the
customer given the e-commerce disruption
of traditional retails Walmart's
business is changing and retail is
always changing to be more online how do
you how is your business changing and
how do you keep those core values or
those values have to change actually as
the business changes I think that the
core values stay the same I think some
of the behaviors probably change in the
way we go to market clearly changes now
tell you a story a few months ago I was
talking to a person from Silicon Valley
who's brilliant and if I said this
person's name you would know their name
and they're in our office in bentonville
and they do some contracting work with
us and they were writing on the
whiteboard how they run their business
and how they design their algorithms and
what they try to do and what their
purpose is and stuff like that we were
talking about the future of business and
it dawned on him after talking about our
mutual businesses for a few minutes that
in some ways we've already done the
harder part so if you want to reach a
large number of customers and grow a
business that's almost five hundred
billion dollars you've got to be
positioned to add a lot of volume to be
able to grow that company so you've got
to be able to not only serve customers
the way you used to serve them in stores
or clubs but you've got to reach them in
new ways and so mobile becomes more
important cetera and his point was you
know you've already got 2.2 million
people you've already got a culture that
when it when it's carried out correctly
at store level this DNA results in good
customer service you've already got the
physical supply chain what you don't
have is the code and the codes easier to
write than it is to go build all the
physical assets that you already have
and I think there's a lot of truth in
that so I it will come back to people
the way people are treated and in turn
how they serve customers whether it's
through some sort of digital experience
or it's a phone bank or it's the text
response they send back to you or it's
the person in person contact you have
with someone in a store those things are
still going to matter so our culture has
got to be even stronger in the future as
we grow then it's been in the past
there's so much more we could touch on
the future of Walmart and Technology and
markets of
but I actually like to shift a little
bit now and focus on your career
specifically and the leadership lessons
that you might have to share with the
MBAs in the audience one of the things
that Dean Mirage I mentioned is you
spent nearly your entire career at
Walmart and I think many of the MBAs in
the audience have already had three or
four employers so I'm curious what's
kept you at Walmart for so long it's
challenging and I mentioned before I
didn't plan on doing this I certainly
didn't plan on retail when I was 16 my
dad moved our family to Northwest
Arkansas to start a dental practice and
I went to say goodbye to my girlfriend
which I thought was the end of the world
because I thought she was it and I'm
standing in her driveway we're probably
both crying or whatever you know and her
dad walks out and he says so what's
going on I said well we're moving to
this little town called Bentonville I've
never heard of it I don't want to go
there my dad's making me I'm not happy
I'll be back and he said you're gonna
end up working for Sam Walton and I said
who okay so when you shop at Walmart I
and I said yeah I guess what you're
gonna end up working for that company
because that's all there isn't
Bentonville turns out that was true
literally all there was when I moved we
move to that little town there was one
stop life it was a McDonald's one pizza
joint and Walmart was it and so you
start hearing about Sam Walton and you
it was a little town so you run into him
or run into other people just you know
being there and I needed a summer job so
the warehouse was hiring at six fifty an
hour and and I took that job because it
paid more than McDonald's but I ended up
meeting this guy the day that I started
it was summertime it was hot and there
was this guy named Johnny unloading
trucks with me and Johnny was bragging
about having two hundred thousand
dollars in profit sharing and I thought
whoa this dude unloads trucks you don't
even have a shirt on maybe I need to pay
attention to where I am you know and you
connect all the dots what I learned
about retail is it's really hard it's
really challenging it's a narrow margin
business you have customers to deal with
you've got to think about marketing
merchandising operations logistics
finance legal real estate compliance
ethics culture global business now
technology you know I meet young people
who are excited to be in the valley and
I come out here quite a bit these days
and the startup thing sounds cool to me
but I haven't heard one yet that is more
challenging than what we're trying to do
if you want hard try to take a 52 year
old business that this size and change
it that's hard and it's worthy
I mean creating a situation where 2.2
million people stay employed and have a
life that's a big deal
so if you want to work at Walmart give
me a call I promise you it'll be hard
one of the you may get some emails now
be careful um one of the interesting
things about your career is you're the
youngest CEO that Walmart's had since
Sam old and you've risen very quickly
through the ladder starting with
unloading trucks and now being CEO too
what you attribute the fact that you
rose so quickly through the ranks at
Walmart well I'm not the only one I mean
I ended up in this job
so people pay attention to it but if you
were inside our company you would meet
many many many people who've had
opportunities and a lot of people who
say I didn't want to be at Walmart I
just wanted a job or I needed to pay my
way through school or whatever and they
end up being here 20 or more years
pause your question how did it happen
yeah I'm still trying to figure that all
right it was a step at a time yeah you
know I loved merchandising I fell into a
situation where the challenge of the
work was something I really liked so I
ended up getting to go to Sam's Club
I've actually been an international
twice then was given the opportunity to
lead our international business and each
one of those steps kind of prepared me
for the next but if I had to answer it
in one word I would say I think it's
just because I love it I really like it
and I'm still learning a lot and so I
think the company needs us this current
leadership group to respect the past and
to not forget the things that made the
company special and be very selective
about what we carry forward so you know
does that distribution center the way it
works provide value to society to our
business to the customer in the future
if it does keep it if it doesn't get rid
of it that kind of attitude forward
looking willing to change my I did not
work for Sam Walton personally I didn't
get to know him a lot but I was around
him a few times
and got to talk to him a couple times
and he if he were here would be driving
change I mentioned earlier if this were
bait whether if you want more people
here if you see if you say to one more
people the only thing that's constant is
they say change well that's a great
platform to operate off of it gives you
the freedom to go do things differently
and that keeps it exciting yeah just I
mean it's clear your excitement for
working at Walmart but one of the things
you haven't mentioned it's kind of
surprises means you haven't talked about
the role of ambition in your career at
Walmart did you know it wasn't staying
at Walmart wasn't part of your calculus
when you joined that you know aiming for
the top job wasn't necessarily something
that you wanted to be chief merchant
someday that was my aspiration I was a
buyer and loved merchandising and I kind
of overshot it so we need when did that
change and what what caused that change
well I was I was a chief merchant at
Sam's Club and I worked for a guy named
Kevin Turner who was our chief
information officer and he got promoted
to run Sam's we were both in our 30s and
Microsoft recruited him away
and Kevin's currently the chief
operating officer at Microsoft so when
he left Lee Scott was our CEO and Lee
Lee came over and he said hey you're
about to hear in the next day or so that
Kevin is leaving to go to Microsoft will
will be putting someone new in Sam's
Club it probably won't be you I'm sure
you're good with that so yeah I love my
job and whoever you send over here I'll
help and he said okay so a few days go
by and he comes back and he says we've
thought about it and we really don't
have anybody else we want to put over
here so you get to be the CEO Sam's Club
that's how I said it wait please quietly
are you taking a lot of Lee Scott
stories but that's that's how that
happened so that forced me to learn a
lot about things other than
merchandising and if I hadn't been given
that opportunity I probably would not
have been given the opportunity to to
lead international which was the most
mind-blowing experience ever I mean I'm
a kid from Arkansas and certainly I've
traveled a lot but sourcing and buying
stuff I've traveled around the world for
a long time now but to be responsible
for a business in 26 countries that's
140 billion dollars with 700 thousand
people and it didn't get to enter Africa
and get to deal with some of the
complexities of the app is just
extraordinary really blessed I actually
like to talk a little bit more about the
role of travel in your career now one of
the core Walmart management philosophies
is cbw a just coaching by walking around
the idea that managers and to interact
with associates and problem-solve on the
store floor but when you're running an
international business you have
employees you have associates all over
the world how did you balance trying to
efficiently run a global organization
when you led the international business
with the need to be physically present
in all those different locations yeah
well first of all you can't be
everywhere so you have to have great
people and we have a Deepti
mean we've got talent in all the markets
you know that we're proud of but there
is no replacement for really
understanding the businesses so I
traveled for five years you know a lot
and loved it enjoyed being on the ground
I've been to places I never really would
have thought I would ever get to go to
and go into stores in Nigeria there are
hours wow what an experience all over
Latin America I've learned a lot about
China don't profess to understand China
but I've been there a lot and fascinated
by it so you have you have to be there
but my responsibility was do we have the
right management talent at the top do we
have the right culture within that
organization and I do spend a lot of
time talking about culture are we
positioned to win are they getting the
resources that they need and in what I
ended up doing in the role that I had is
to get our leadership team to focus on
the things that we had in common
maybe this is a good way to answer the
question when I moved into the job
everybody told me you really need to
understand what's different you got to
focus on the local differences don't try
to run it from here I think some of the
lessons from Germany were probably
playing out in that in that direction
but after doing it for five years all I
can tell you is everybody's the same do
people around the world are thinking
about the same things they're thinking
about their family their thing about
their career they're thinking about you
know the vacation they're going to take
they're reading a lot of the same media
they're we're more and more the same
even during the five years that I was
international I could see a difference
in people and I remember one morning
getting up in Japan and reading the same
news story I'd read the day before in
the u.s. about Angelina Jolie I'm like
okay we're all on the same page here but
products are becoming more the same and
the last year I was international I
started asking people when I was in a
store I did once in Costa Rica for
example I would say show me something
that is uniquely Costa Rican in this
store and they would look at each other
and say ok so they took the over this
bottle that was labeled salsa it looked
like a1 sauce and when I turned it
around it said Unilever on the back and
people just increasingly had a hard time
showing me anything that that's unique
now local produce locally grown product
things that are you know produce really
near a store still matter and we want to
source those things but I could see kind
of a global wave of commonality
happening and that was fascinating Wow
you mentioned one of the things that
it's common people you meet all around
the world is there everybody's thinking
about work and family and trying to
balance these things and I'm curious
especially you had a career that
involved so much international travel
and so much responsibility I think that
many of the MBAs in the audience are
also thinking about how to balance their
careers with other obligations that have
in their life so I'm curious you know
what have you learned to try to make
that balance work because you have a
family and sons invent evil and you know
how what advice do you have to give to
MBAs who are kind of embarking on trying
to start that figure out that balance
after they graduate I think it's
personal you know you guys have to solve
it for yourselves based on what's
important to you for me life came in
phases so there's a period of time where
my kids were little shelling I have two
boys and I did not want to miss like
those little three-on-three soccer
scrums with a six year old you know so
being there at that age mattered a lot
by the time I was responsible for
international my boys were teenagers and
they were like he'd been gone dad I mean
he didn't miss me that much it's very
different than when they were in
elementary school and stuff so there's
probably a time and a place for
everything and you just need to manage
that pay attention to it pay attention
to yourself you know are you getting the
right rest are you taking care of your
body are you right minded and in in the
jobs that you're going to have
your decisions will really matter so
you've got to be prepared to make
important decisions and you can't do
that if you're exhausted as look at
least you won't do it very well so I
think you need to know yourself and know
what's important to you whether its
family or faith or whatever it is you've
got a you got to be right on that note
in making important decisions as you
know CEO of the world's largest company
your decisions have a lot of weight they
affect a lot of people there's a lot of
those big dollar amounts at play here
can you tell us a story of the difficult
decision that you've had to make over
the course of your career yeah I mean
just the round of decisions we got
through making in announcing last
Thursday are the first things that come
to mind because they're recent the the
importance of having great people around
you a good team that can help you think
about an issue you will not face very
many things where you have 100% of the
knowledge and the image that pops into
my mind all the time we were having this
conversation yesterday with the
leadership team about the future of our
supply chain and we had ecommerce
leaders and people who are steeped in
logistics in the room and what you
literally saw play out on a whiteboard
is people putting pieces of a puzzle
together and the people that have been
doing it for a long time said here's
what it looks like and the e-commerce
people said yes but you're missing this
piece and then of another person said
what if we do this and all of a sudden a
picture emerged on the board of the
future of our supply chain that was
better than it would have been with any
individual so in this latest rain set of
changes that we've made there were
different people people from within our
HR or people area that contributed to
training in a big way there were other
people who said for us to run great
stores when you've got to change the
structure there were other people that
said you know the starting wage needs to
really be thought out and here's how we
should think about it and when people
make great decisions you just need to
let them you know I don't make every
decision in Walmart don't want to make
every decision Walmart if I do my job
well I'm not making very many decisions
because the team is doing it but every
once in a while I've got
make some and they better be right and I
need to have listened to others to try
and sort it out
many of them are unclear by the time
they get to my desk if they were easy
somebody else would have solved them so
knowing sometimes this isn't going to
get any clearer there's more there's no
more data that will help me make this
decision I'm just going to have to go
with my gut you have to do that
sometimes I have a lot more than I could
ask a lot more things I'm curious about
but I want to make sure that we give our
audience a chance to ask some questions
I think we'll start with a question from
Twitter
what do you think that future of the US
grocery market will be in five to ten
years and more specifically are you
worried about the rise of the discount
stores future of grocery that's a big
question and I think grocery will be
more food will be more focused on
quality in some ways it'll be more local
definitely this huge trend towards you
know organic and gluten-free that's
where the growth is and quality the way
you handle the supply chain the way
produce is handled all the way through
the process is going to be increasingly
important I do think grocery home
delivery will play a role although I
don't think it will be in the United
States more than 10 percent of business
anytime soon in the UK we've been doing
grocery home delivery for 15 years and
it's it's still well under 10 percent of
our business
picking up your groceries in the parking
lot or in an off-site pickup location
that will happen and is happening we've
got experience with that in the UK you
may have read we recently announced some
pilots here in the US for grocery pickup
and grocery delivery Denver in Phoenix
so other places so we've got testing
going on the way customers will take
product will be different than what
they've done in the past we've got a
pickup location we opened in Bentonville
last year where you can't go in the
store and shop you order on your mobile
device ahead of the time and you just go
through and drive into a slot and we put
it in your trunk for you and that test
is going well dan just reported to me
his wife had an experience today and no
substitutions in less than a five-minute
wait so we're making progress on
learning how to do that so grocery is
going to change I think we got the team
to help sort it out we don't have the
reputation that we want to have today
for quality that's a big
area focus for us but it's achievable
okay let's go here first hi I'm a band
I'm an MBA one here first of all thanks
so much for coming to speak with us so
there's a report released last year that
said US taxpayers subsidize Walmart to
the tune of 6.2 billion dollars in food
stamps Medicaid welfare I guess how do
you respond to the critics who are who
are saying you know whether it's six
billion or three billion or whatever the
number is but the biggest company the
world the wealthiest family in the
country shouldn't should be paying its
workers enough that that money doesn't
need to be there at all yeah I
understand the criticism first thing
that comes to mind is we pay almost two
percent of the corporate taxes in the
country so I don't feel very subsidized
okay but the issue you're raising goes
to respect and it goes to opportunity
and what I was talking about earlier is
how I feel about it we're a company that
gives people an opportunity to go do
more now where we put that first rung on
the ladder matters and I don't know the
statistics about how many Walmart
associates are currently on government
assistance but we don't want any of them
to be on government assistance because
we want them to be able to move up that
ladder and we want to set that first
letter in the right first rung on the
ladder in the right place so we think
about things like health care and
accessibility of health care starting
wage rate what we do with 401k program
so that people who can save have an
opportunity to save helping them with an
education helping them get their GED if
they don't have it providing skills for
people who are learning English as their
second language we're trying to create
that meritocracy that I described and I
think the decision we made most recently
to put a billion dollars into our us
associates is an indication that we do
care and that we are listening and you
know we're always going to have critics
and critics have their own agenda I
don't expect to ever escape that but if
our associates and our customers know
that we have good hearts and there were
well-intentioned and that we're taking
action in the right direction I think
we'll be in good shape
this working area I'm Daniel I'm an MBA
one as well I'm interested to hear you
talk about outside scrutiny both from a
media perspective and also from the wall
street stock analyst perspective as CEO
you know you're the steward of
shareholder value obviously over the
long term you're probably never going to
have the New York Times and you'll
always have Fox News in your corner got
it
think about anybody in our corner I'd be
great but so you know in more recent
times we've obviously seen this
incredibly exciting announcement as a
you know an avid Walmart customer I'm
you know very appreciative of what
you've done for your employees but every
single press announcement has also said
and the decision coming after six
quarters of same-store sales being down
right what link you know is this coming
because as a management team you have to
be really sensitive to what the street
is saying and what the press is saying
or at the end of the day do you have to
take a 52-year view or 152 year view and
say they'll always be critical of us in
cycles and we have to keep our eyes on
the prize hmm that's it and keep keeping
your eyes on your eye on the prize and
thinking a bit longer term is the way we
feel about it and you mention though the
Walton family one of the benefits of
having the Walton family own as much of
the company as they do is that you get
to take a long-term view so this is a
family who benefited greatly from the
creation of Walmart who cares about our
culture cares about our associates cares
about sustainability so we have a board
of directors including our chairman Rob
Walden who asked us to think about the
long term and to do what's right for the
business for the long term so sometimes
I will say something like a big part of
my job is to help position the company
to be here 50 years from now I'll never
make it in this job anything near 50
years so really I'm worried probably
about the next 10 you know in a more
tangible way so whether it's the
investment it's in people or the
investments in technology I mean we
everybody knows we're losing money in
e-commerce in the short term to build
capabilities that will help us in the
long term
that mindset is vital and it's vital to
surviving if you look at the history of
retail you could take a snapshot of the
top 10 retailers in the world by decade
and I carry this around on a PDF on my
phone to remind me it changes a lot and
fast so you'll see a company like
JCPenney or Sears or others who rise to
a top spot and then they fall a big
challenge at Walmart is to be relevant
in a way for customers such that we can
grow five years from now and ten years
from now because history is actually
against us but the advantage we have is
that we can think long term and we have
resources if you make the right choices
invest in the right places you can do it
but these choices do matter hi emily
ambrose thanks so much for coming to
speak with us i'm really interested in
hearing how you think about walmart
relative to amazon so what scares you
about amazon how do you think walmart
competes with amazon and then ultimately
how do you think walmart beats Amazon is
Jeff here oh the way that I was taught
to think about competition in walmart is
that you should do everything you can to
learn from them so you could feel
threatened by a great competitor if you
wanted to but it's actually more
productive to think about what are they
doing that the customer likes that we
can learn from and I think Amazon and
others have shown us that the customer
wanted access to a broader assortment
they loved being able to do it in an
easy way you know doing it online and
increasingly mobile has much less
friction than getting in your car and
driving to a store when you don't want
to so we've been thinking about these
four different dimensions the first one
might call it as the breadth of
assortment and when we started opening
supercenters got 120,000 SKUs versus a
grocery store or a category killer it
out it out assorted those competitors
you could do one-stop shopping more
effectively so we're winning on
assortment but now the Internet's
changed what assortment means an
assortment looks more like tens of
millions of items than 120,000 items
values different price transparencies
increased
sess is different you can get more
delivered you can pick more up in the
future than you did in the past and then
the experience has changed now we have a
lot of customers that are using their
mobile devices on the floor of our store
they're using it for navigation they're
using it to search they're using it to
buy an item they couldn't find in the
toy department when they were looking
for it those kinds of things so the way
we ultimately win against anybody is we
work across those four dimensions in a
way that's unique leveraging the supply
chain and the assets we have so that we
end up giving customers a better value
across a broader assortment and help
them save time and hopefully surprise
and delight them with a couple things
along the way so the investment in
digital matters and the way we put it
together with stores is how we'll win do
you think our next question from Twitter
wraps so you mentioned that going
international is very hard one of your
biggest investments has been an ad star
which is a UK grocery market how
successful do you think that investment
has been and how do you think a star
welfare going forward in the changing
retailing and scape in the UK yeah I
didn't answer the second part of the
discounter question and in the UK is
certainly seeing Aldi and Lidl and the
discounters do very well so we feel
their presence as it relates to as in
our business in the UK by the way if you
don't know we've got over 50 different
retail brands around the world and in
the UK we're known as de so what we have
to do in that circumstance is to make
sure that our opening price points the
entry-level price points into each
category are strong and the qualities
right then we have to offer service or
assortment with a premium product that
enables us to win on assortment so going
back to those competitive dimensions
that I was just describing some
combination of those four applied in a
market delivers the winning formula and
we may have to tweak it here and there
depending on what customers are offered
from competition in a particular market
as there's been a great investment
terrific talent mark our current Walmart
us chief operating officer is British
her name is Judith McKenna and she's now
responsible for 1.3 million u.s. so she
it's which is fun because she uses
British phrases that most of us don't
understand we're teaching a new form of
English but you know this this
acquisition has been one of our better
ones hi my name is Mahara and I'm an MBA
- you talked about e-commerce and the
importance of the digital platforms and
I was wondering if you could elaborate a
bit more about your omni-channel
strategy and how do you plan on breaking
the organizational silos in a 52 year
old organization where your ecommerce
department and your retail branch are so
far apart yeah that's hard we've got
some members of our e-commerce team here
now and if you asked you know what could
threaten Walmart one of the answers I
would give you as internal ways of
working know-how we have new ideas that
may emerge from California but we have
knowledge and experience in our core
business a lot of it in our home office
in Bentonville and how do you get those
people to work together in such a way
that the outcomes better than it would
have been individually that's one of our
big challenges so we currently have some
work underway to look at incentive
alignment and how strategies are pulled
together to make sure that they are
cohesive and do work together a lot of
it boils down to trust and relationships
and people being willing willing to
listen to each other so I was talking to
somebody recently and they are one on
one side of the house but don't cross
both sides and I said you know you may
have 80% of that figured out problem is
I don't know which 80% and neither do
you the other person in the room may
know the other twenty your job is to
help communicate what you think about
the ad but also listen so that you can
find the other 20 and you attitudinally
that's kind of what we need from our
leadership team right now and I think
we're generally getting there but
there's some things that we need to do
to make it easier so that it doesn't
feel like it takes decision by consensus
which can kill you to speed matters too
so if you worked inside Walmart today
this would be one of the hot topics
there's a phrase that's emerged this
year who owns the D
which means ultimately who is the
decision-maker because people want to
know so they can move with speed and I'm
trying to help us figure out how do we
move with speed but also use the
appropriate collective wisdom Marissa
Mayer is on our board and we were
talking in a board meeting about this a
while back and she said something like
you know within our business there may
be just making this up eight people who
should really weigh in on a decision and
sometimes we seek feedback from 40 I'm
just going to quit worrying about the 40
worry about the 8 make the decision and
get moving and if the other 32 have
something to contribute they'll have to
jump in front of the bus and try to stop
us because we got to keep moving
and it feels like that within Walmart
too we got to get the right few people
in the room to make the best decision
and then get on with it and in a
business of our size and our age that's
a challenge
great question hi I'm Michael e I'm a
first year medical student and and I'm
really interested in the rise of retail
health Walmart is clearly a big player
in this space so I was just wondering if
you could comment on the future of
Walmart with regards to breaking into
the healthcare industry yeah the
healthcare industry looks complicated
from here we just our retailer but the
the long-standing pharmacy and optical
businesses that we've had we've got some
Sam's Clubs that do a job with hearing
and hearing aids clinics we are doing
we've tried several things with clinic
clinics third parties partnering with
hospitals in some cases doing more of
the infrastructure on our own our
customers want it because they want
affordable health care that's accessible
and easy and so I think what you'll see
us do is continue to slowly move into
healthcare in the appropriate ways in a
way that serves customers and helps us
with traffic but I think we should be
very thoughtful and cautious as it
relates to what we do to make sure that
what we deliver builds trust with
customers if we rushed into clinics and
try to put them in too many stores too
fast I'm certain the quality wouldn't be
what we need it to be
so who we partner with and how we go
about it matters and we're learning and
we'll keep moving that direction because
we think our customers want us to
healthcare is complicated up close to I
think we have time for one more audience
question in the back corner here hi I'm
Nene and I'm MBA one you mentioned the
walton family's commitment to
sustainability and I was wondering how
you thought that has played out at
Walmart if it ever doesn't make
short-term business sense and how some
of those decisions might play out in the
company that doesn't have that kind of
family commitment and ability to think
long term yeah one example would be
capital investment so if you think about
renewable energy I think we're at about
twenty-eight percent renewable energy
globally at the moment around the world
some markets are ahead of others Mexico
is actually one of our leaders in this
space they do a great job with
renewables capital investment in LED
lighting in a store for example which
might have a higher upfront level of
investment but payback over a period of
time we're very comfortable making that
kind of decision so we were the first
retailer to go to China with LED
lighting for example what we invest
related to refrigeration and the type of
refrigeration that cuts down on
greenhouse gases that has a little bit
of a short-term negative impact maybe
more than a little bit but we do it for
those reasons that you decided so I
think that's an example of where a long
term disposition helps and and that does
ultimately flow back to our board of
directors the Doug I'd like to conclude
by asking a question that's become a bit
of a tradition here at Stanford
all the MBAs in the audience will have
answered this question as part of their
applications to the GSB what matters
most to you and why
I'm still trying to please my
grandmother that was a little too
personal wouldn't it that's probably
true Am I you know my family matters a
lot the faith family matter a lot to me
I'm also very competitive person and I
like to win and falling into Walmart has
just been more than I could have ever
dreamt so you know I don't know what you
guys are all gonna go do but I hope you
find a place where you know you're in
the right spot and if you're not move
and go somewhere else you probably all
eventually end up at Walmart which will
be fine we'll see well thank you for
ending up at Stanford it's been a
pleasure to host you please join me in
thanking dunk for joining us here today